fight a lot as a kid in Victorville it
was just like everybody's talking
all the time and did I fight I never
been a street fighter in my life I was
scared I'm scared I'm actually scared to
street fight now not now but now you've
got to be more scared because you could
get up and then you can't do this
or you could figure out yeah yeah but as
a kid I was terrified to fight it's like
what were the types of uh kids that were
I guess thrown down that made it uh a
scary possibility nothing it's just the
fact that we're fighting like it just
felt like right I would get scared is
there a tough area Victorville yeah well
where I do Adelanto is pretty it's
pretty tough yeah
it's all good how'd you get into the
fight game were you in were you uh I was
a baseball player at six years old right
and then uh I was I didn't like the team
sports so I asked my uncle I said is
there any sports one-on-one and he
showed me a clip of boxing I just saw
him and do it that was it who did he
show you I don't even know you remember
he just showed me two guys fighting I
said I'll do it and where do you go to
do it I just trained in garage